there's a certain Grace and Power about
horses and donkeys they have a sort of
stoic indifference to the world that I
love but when does horsing around
actually end up being dangerous
[Music]
oh
there's a tail going at the same time
they're so adorable I mean it's
something about the size of the ears
compared to the size of the animal how
their ears are just so big
this donkey is demonstrating one of the
things that makes donkeys unique it's
fraying at the Hee Haw what it's doing
is actually making sounds on the exhale
and the inhale so it's going
and making sounds both in and out
whereas a horse when it wants to Nay
just is on the exhale
and they use this spraying for
everything they're angry hungry when
they see a friend when they're horny
they're all just gonna hear oh I think
is that the right way
actually it's the other way
[Music]
look at it it's so fluffy is that a baby
or is that like a miniature donkey
oh I'm coming I'm coming here I come I
can hear you
there's such
personable sort of creatures aren't they
and it's really funny that donkeys are
sort of referred to as being idiots
because it's really not the case at all
it's not like they're Einstein or
anything but they're actually pretty
smart and they form really strong social
bonds so they will form a pair bond with
an individual like their special friend
and sometimes those pair bonds can go
into species so sometimes the pear Bond
can be between a donkey and a human and
it means that when they're separated
from each other the donkey will use all
of its powers intellectual and otherwise
to get back to its friend and it's going
to do things like climb over walls and
go through brambles
look I said that was smart but you know
everyone has their moments
[Music]
no you're so pretty whoa
I mean to be fair that gave me a little
fright as well get it boy get it Joy no
don't get it get it get it get it you're
gonna get your ass now
went through the fence at the end quite
dangerous that snapping turtle tried to
give that horse what for
horses are really curious animals but
they also are prey to other animals and
that means they've got a really highly
developed flight or fight response when
they get a fright
one of the weapons that horses have
is their kick which is incredibly fast
and incredibly strong a horse's kick
goes as quick as 320 kilometers an hour
in fact there was a case of a man who
got kicked in the chest by a horse and
he actually went into cardiac arrest
because of it horses will break your
heart
oh look at this picturesque Mountain
scene with um wild horses and it was
they're not wild
oh oh nope nope nope
oh yeah
oh yeah this is a classic case of the
human not knowing how to interpret horse
communication the horse gave clear signs
to that human to not approach as soon as
he started to come towards it with his
handout the horse raised its head up and
it put its ears back and this really
aggressive tail flip that really really
obviously tells you that they're angry
and he didn't listen
so he got bitten that's what happens
when you approach animals I mean horses
can bite strong enough to break bones if
they want to then you need to give it
some personal space
I don't know what they're putting water
on it for
[Music]
it oh hey
oh
[Music]
that's the core strength on that cat
though
[Music]
horses explore a lot with their lips
they're actually really sensitive and
gorgeously velvety if you ever get close
to them they've actually got really
coarse little whiskers and they function
like a cat's whiskers they receive
sensory information and send it straight
up to the brain and one of the reasons
why they actually need to have this
sensory apparatus at the end of their
muzzle is because the way their eyes are
placed means that they really can't see
what's directly in front of them on the
ground
I'm not sure that the horse is actually
being mean there I think it was just
exploring but then sometimes horses just
can be
horses and donkeys with all their
wonderful shapes and sizes and
capabilities have coexisted with humans
for thousands of years and with all of
that charm and just a little bit of a
nibble I think that we want them around
us for thousands of years to come
[Music]
thank you